all right we're back here on overtime
and I'm gonna ask the questions that
people have written in bill was this
country really is dumb as you say I do
always say that or is it just getting
meaner
oh it's getting meaner and dumber but
definitely meaner I mean when you see
those Republican debates and people
cheering for executions and you know
hating gay soldiers and but that you you
think that's meaner than 100 years ago
that I don't know because I'm not a
historian you may be right I think I
think we ought with these two things
that are almost always true one is that
the world keeps getting better into is
the people always think it's getting
worse
yeah and that it's very when I look back
in like my dad looking at 1970 you know
where they've shot students at Kent
State
the president is legally crazy they are
intellectual oh honey the wars are going
on like crazy in Vietnam there's no end
to anything the inflation is through the
roof it just looks like it might look
worse you know and maybe we just got
older there's a new book out about this
about how people were just what you're
saying they think it's getting worse but
actually when you look at what was going
on in the 20th century there are fewer
people starving yeah you were people
dying it more more all right those
things right we had things happening now
too
you know bad things happening now but
you have to look at the big picture I
mean no polio but I actually ends of
argument I actually don't think it's
because people are getting better I
think re oh of course
or instead I mean of course they're not
either no institution yeah restrain us
more but I just think like you know they
always say the police are the thin blue
line if you take them away god knows
what would have I don't I think they'd
be really good you think people are
really good very good yeah and here fast
that is such [ __ ] that is Clara
Jordan if you took away the police it
would be absolute but you know to that
it would be the red clay do you think
even the pastor agrees with me what
between two 80s I want to talk about the
book and people raise their hands and
say if there is no heaven or hell
Oh what's to stop me from just raping
and killing anybody I want and I always
go who's on your list cuz my list of
people to kill that's zero
I think everybody's list of people if
you have someone near listed you would
actually kill oh just just on this panel
you think that without God they would
just kill everybody now who's on your
list no I don't think it people would
kill everybody if there were no God
think people who rank good but it is all
relative I mean I don't I think people
are good the problem is none of us is
good enough to meet God's standard
that's a god Steve I think I think
people are situational when you put them
in a situation where they can commit
heinous crimes they would I I use the
example about helped you remember the
Nazi guard Ivan the Terrible John de
Munich he was dated um but didn't know
well but yes of course
okay well this guy was I mean it was it
was a bit to bed whether he really was
either the turbo if they think he
Richard yeah okay so he was during the
war the World War two when it was okay
to torture people and kill them he was a
vicious Nazi prison guard okay fine he
did that then after the war he slipped
out of the country and for the next 40
years worked as an auto worker in Ohio
courteous on time excellent worker
didn't bother anybody quite in detention
and benefits exactly so in other words
when the situation prohibited from
acting like a yes a savage he did not
and I think that's P but you also when
they could be Nazi prison guards lots of
them you start naming people who have
done horrendous things and then I'll
name the six billion alive now who
haven't and again it's because they
didn't have the Opera
gonna be or if they were I good in that
just I really think so I think that
we've our Marauder The Saturdays outside
surely or you'd protect your face
certainly the Milgram experiments and
all that stuff that shows us right
negative thing there's no doubt that
that's on your side but that is not
proof that everyone is there to play a
game it's baseball or soccer or business
or life they're giving rules and
referees it's just like we all need to
agree on what are the rules of the game
there are some rules have to come from
your heart and some rules on there it's
a little much regulators yes I don't
insist on extent human nature has been
the same for thousands of course we have
a good time to evolve on that yeah
that's right your rules don't make
anybody any holier there were six every
Wayne Steve oh look they don't like this
whole er
but it duck white off another but police
forces do they do but they don't wake
you've had her inside they change your
behavior but I don't change these around
player when that when the police set
decided to sit home in 1992 here we had
riots and we would have them again if
they did okay do you believe that sex
appeal is a factor in house News
Corporation's choose their female
anchors I hope so that's right now if
they could just do that with stewardess
oh so she's a man I think that make me
make that sell okay what did you think
of the president's timing for directing
the Justice Department's crackdown on
medical cannabis dispensaries is this a
diversion a diversion why did he invade
Cambodia he's invading Americans it's I
mean Astor's I thought it was awful if
Amy know you feel already holding my
nose to vote for him because he would he
did with the Bush tax cut if I have to
hold something else prohibition I think
we should look it's just that simple
I think we should have an honest debate
the marijuana law should have
liberalized but they shouldn't be done
under the guise that everybody is
getting medical marijuana
some people need levitical marijuana but
most of that is like you tell us or
nerdy Marilee actually do it rather than
have this I agree been baked medicine
marijuana yeah I've never had any
marijuana sip of alcohol in my life whoa
but I want everybody to be able to if
you're not able to put what you want in
your body you're not living in a free
let's do look in the front
there's more people to have that right
freedom and that's from someone who may
be the only one in the panel is a sip of
alcohol ever Jack Daniels ice cream
talked about it the only plug okay I
haven't even had that job because it's
not because I think it's sinful okay I'm
an atheist so I don't do it you know to
make the arguments I'm battle thinkin
century what about when Catholics drink
the blood with that it's really wine
well that's one of those strange
teachings how he's talking about it's
hot in the Bible that's nasty business
command Ernesto juice
yeah we knew Welch's grape juice in our
church you'd love that a lot better okay
and that's what the problem is the two
of you could have a separate show I I
think we could have a morning show
I don't like we do you don't know you'd
be like Kathie Lee and the yellow bomb I
think it's a buddy cop movie that's
right yeah that's right it is an eight
year Christian but they're both tops
all right we gotta go
you